manchmal überkommt nicht plötzlich ein
unfassbarer durst nach grundwasser ab
aber kann man es noch bedenkenlos
trinken
[Musik]
wenn sie die neue düngeverordnung
schießen finde ich die donnerstags für
dünger ist das die antwort auf fridays
for future was ist breit ist future
massentierhaltung und nitrat da gibt es
keinen ursächlichen zusammenhang der
massentierhaltung produziert ja
dementsprechend auch mehr gülle die muss
irgendwohin
das ist unbedingt unser grundwasser ist
nicht versorgt ich komme aus
ostfriesland
es ist nicht versorgt der boden nimmt
das auf wir haben auch einen anderen
erst nimmt der boden das auf und wir
haben weitergeben da gibt es nicht
weiter nein nein
und warum zeigen dann die messwerte das
nitrat und was die da bin ich
überfordert
die müssen ausgegeben und wir müssen
alle zusammen rücken das ist nicht nur
bauern mit julia klöckner sondern es
müssen wieder auch verbraucher müssen
zusammen wie ich gehen weil sonst kommen
lebens werden nicht mehr aus deutschland
ich weiß nicht was jemand möchte von
euch da wir wollen ja vor allem keinen
keine scheiße im wasser
glückliche wahl keine gefahr ist vorbei
ja ich weiß das auch bei mir
verwandtschaft irgendwo wer weiß
vielleicht sehe ich so wenn es mal
winken also sind die peckelsheimer ich
weiß gar nicht ob ich so sehe nirgendwo
sind sie da hinten ja genau
jetzt weiß ja wo sind die box euro für
das kind war so eigene brunnen zehn
milligramm nitrat das ist so in ordnung
dass für sie ist es gut für mich ist es
kann dann ganz deutschland aus ihrem
boden trinken nein dafür gibt das nicht
her
merken sie selbst nicht von der pflanze
erwarten also sagen sie ruhig ich bin
die pflanze stellt sich vor ich bin die
pflanze ja dann saniert dass du jetzt
mit dem ruhig du du musst mit dem dünger
klarkommen den den db geben können
maximum aber muss dafür dafür sorgen wir
weizen in der qualität produzieren dass
man ein brot heraus machen kann kombi
mit klar könnten können sie jetzt
einfach als pflanze sagen aber ob man ja
auch ja aber ist man kann es in der
praxis der konstantesten lügen ja nicht
ganz kann ich nicht reden
gutes gegenargument
[Musik]
wir bauen sind langsam nur noch gefühlt
der buhmann der nation
und das kann ja auch nicht sein dass die
gülle dass sich die unternehmen die die
gülle durch die gegend kutschieren sich
100 kilometer sind wir ja tagtäglich
dass die sich dann eine goldene nase
verdienen und die gülle vergoldet recht
richtig
[Musik]
wo wir heute gar nicht darüber geredet
haben was ist denn mit diesen ganzen
abwässern aus diesen ganzen
kanalisationen aus den großstädten oder
sind die denn alle noch dicht hat keiner
drüber geredet auch jetzt sind weder die
großstädter gleich voll scheiße glauben
dass nitrat nur wegen der bauern ins
wasser kommt ist falsch vor 500 jahren
waren naturwissenschaftliche
zusammenhänge die mir nicht verstehen
konnte immer ganz einfach zu erklären
man hatte die hexe und die frau brandi
war schuld heute ist es wenn das licht
langsam angst dass sie mich gleich
betäubungslose kastrieren
ja ich kein problem mit ich habe darüber
womit ich kann das routiniert aber ich
mache das nicht bei erwachsenen
[Musik]
ich habe viele nette bauern kennen
gelernt und zum glück nimmt mich einer
mit nach köln und damit zurück ins
studio ist dass diese hans de schreibt
über die heute show ihr seid die
richtigen links [ __ ] besonders welke
die stradivari unter den arschgeigen bei
euch smileys freudentränen freudentränen
freudentränen freund rennkurs mit herz
vielen dank für ihr freundliches flugweg
für ein exklusives geigensolo von oliver
welke
abonnieren sie den kanal